um what is the latest with kit ma
obviously he's uh incarcerated have you
got to speak with him do you know what's
going on with him yeah I talked to him
on the phone for like two minutes on uh
the other day when I was with Lupe and
four extras and uh they there's a new
girl named carb doll who KPM has
apparently landed himself in a
relationship with since he got locked up
that's the level of RIS that my man KPM
has we're going to call him rmac is that
he uh basically like found a new
girlfriend from behind the G wall which
is insane so is there any sort of uh
idea like is it's a federal case yeah
and like he's saying that well I I I've
heard that the average sentence would be
five years damn he's saying three to
five over the
phone I don't know would
you cuz I saw like sh Knight's got this
new podcast that's over the phone M do
you think they be a way to keep KPM
involved in content via the phone that
is a good idea I don't know I haven't
tuned into that that just to try to keep
something going keeping some motion
going with them I don't know you know
like I've never had good luck with
talking to people on the phone in jail
and having them tell me anything
interesting you know I remember I used
to talk to Draco after he'd been locked
up for a year or two and they don't
usually seem eager to tell you about all
their fights and everything and then the
audio quality is [__] so I don't know I
mean yeah I mean they obviously aren't
going to snitch on themselves like I got
into it last night you know but I don't
know maybe I I just feel like it he was
on such a he was on such a climb right
now like I just watch that neon video
where he threw the hot dog at dude and
was like suck that [__] up with your ass
hot dog ever oh my God I was like kit ma
is on his way to being in movies this
guy's on his [__] way so when I saw
he got arrested it was like it was I
don't even know dude I was it was just
heartbreaking yeah and I think like you
know my girl always saw me interviewing
him and like didn't really get it or
like never paid attention to his [__]
and then she hung out out of them two
days on set and by the end of that she
was like he's the funniest person I've
ever met hilarious and uh like I like he
was the star of the show on the Lena
reality show like he just kind of stole
it like he just was so good on camera
and so funny and I actually don't really
think we would have had a show if it
wasn't for him or at least it wouldn't
have it wouldn't have been entertaining
it wouldn't have been anywhere near as
funny because it's like every 30 seconds
to a minute there's just a crit ma line
in the show and all the porn dudes are
just very
normal for the most part they're like
you know if you want to be a porn star
and you want to be accepted in the game
the name of the game is make everybody
like you don't offend anybody don't piss
anybody off even like the other day I
made a joke about uh Violet Myers on a
podcast with l d and my girl and and he
said would you bust in her and I go hell
no I wouldn't bust in her she's Mexican
which you and me get the joke Mexican
girls get pregnant a lot whatever yeah I
mean I I I have two Mexican children my
girl scared me right away she's like you
should you should call Violet and make
sure that she's not going to get
offended by about that which I was like
okay I feel you cuz in the porn game you
just really want everybody to like you
cuz it could be one or two girls that
don't [__] with you that could really
have a negative impact on your career
well I've noticed you've been you've
even even like some of the stuff you
told me off camera you've kept close to
you and not revealed on camera even
though you could but it's kind of like a
Unwritten rule type of Industry I am a
believer in the the porn mans code where
you just anything weird that happens on
set even in this conversation there are
things have been complicated behind the
scenes on set whatever and we just don't
talk about it everything was great
everything always was great nobody ever
had a hard time getting a boner
everybody finished as soon as they
wanted to it's just like I feel like
you're not supposed to talk about that
stuff like you're not supposed to film
The DP like the CRP Mac DP d double
penetration it's so funny moving to La
when my boy was telling me about getting
dpd once I was like bro I didn't know
about you know the gang DP as opposed to
yeah being a sick [__] and you can't win
assuming double penetration you're not
allowed to win the DP yeah I me if I'm
getting dpd and I start winning more
people enter the DP and beat the [__]
out of you so you got to just
just I mean then but I still think
you're supposed to try to fight you got
to kind of put up a fight but you don't
want to you don't want to win you can't
whoop his ass or the DP will probably
become a lot more extreme I think yeah
uh that's interesting well they tell me